on Thursday the Department of Homeland
Security announced its official
revocation of President Obama's
executive amnesty for illegal immigrant
parents according to the Associated
Press quote Homeland Security Secretary
John Kelly formally revoked a policy
memo that created the deferred action
for parents of Americans program the
revocation came on the fifth anniversary
of another effort that has protected
hundreds of thousands of young
immigrants from deportation in reality
Obama's DAPA program deferred action for
parents arrival program never took
effect the federal judge had stayed at
pointing out that Obama had exceeded his
authority it's unclear whether Trump is
actually going to begin supporting more
illegal immigrant parents especially
since Trump administration has continued
to fight back against deportation of
so-called dreamers actually in the exact
same memo announcing the revocation of
DAPA
the homeland security secretary said the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
have remained in place breaking a key
campaign promise as Daniel Horowitz of
Conservative review pointed out last
week quote Trump's DHS has issued almost
125,000 daca cars per Obama's unlawful
deferred action for childhood arrivals
ordered to illegal aliens through the
second quarter of this fiscal year
January through March this surpasses the
122,000 level of amnesty cards issued
during the final quarter of Obama's
presidency October 1st through December
31st 2016 which means the Trump
administration is not even slowing down
the pace just last week Kelley assured
Congress we are not not not targeting
daca registrants right now and pled with
Congress to pass comprehensive
immigration reform so will the Trump
administration actually begin keeping
its commitment to begin supporting those
Obama attempted to protect under DAPA
it's difficult to tell that uncertainty
is still a step up from the Obama
administration's obvious unwillingness
to consider deportation for entire
classes of illegal immigrants and
Trump's bakery has had some predictable
results the number of people attempting
to cross the border illegally has
dropped dramatically but there is no
question that the Trump administration's
open position on daca is a new shocking
development for a president who pledged
widespread deportations of illegal
immigrants as a key campaign promise I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
I want to talk a lot about what's going
on with President Trump tweeting I want
to talk about what's going on Pernik and
my dad is going to stop by for the
mailbag in just a little while but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Indo Chino so Enzo Chino is the
place for custom men's suit there's
nothing that makes a guy look better
than being in a custom tailored suit
Enzo chinos calm makes that happen you
can first of all visit their showroom
I've been to their showroom they've
actually helped me figure out what to
wear they've shown what kind of fabrics
work they've shown what the fit should
look like
enzo Chino calm you pick your fabric to
choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings and more you
submit your measurements online or you
can go to their store and they will
actually set it for you with Taylor does
the work or you can actually just be
measured by your your friends or family
and you can send those measurements into
indogene oh and get the best-looking
suit you will ever have I actually just
wore this suit on Fox News the other day
it's that nice and right now if you go
to Enzo chinos calm and you use Shapiro
at checkout that's ing o CH I and O calm
right now you enter Shapiro at checkout
you can get any premium Enzo Chino suit
for just three hundred and seventy nine
dollars that is 50% off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
is made from scratch made just for you
this is not an off the rack at their
tailoring this is made just for you
again Indo chinos calm promo code
Shapiro for any premium suit for just
three hundred $79 and free shipping
every tie it's the best buy you will
ever make when it comes to suits I mean
an author actually can cost exactly the
same amount of money but isn't fit to
you Indo Chino calm makes that happen
use that promo code Ben so that they
know that we sent you again it's ing o
CH I and O calm my favorite seats where
Enzo chinos calm okay so I want to talk
a little bit before we get to president
Trump's Twitter I want to talk about a
problem that I see arising on the right
and it's a mistake that's being made in
response to the left being awful on
issues of free speech left has been
awful on issues for free speech for
years I should know when I speak on
college campuses I get protested there
sometimes riots I've been banned from
college campuses and the left uses a
particular logic when it comes to this
the particularly odjick that the left
uses when it comes to banning me is that
words
violence words prompt violence therefore
we can't have Shapiro here if Shapiro
says the man is a man and a woman is a
woman then that could prompt somebody to
do something nasty to a transgender
person and therefore we have to ban
Shapiro from campus this is sort of the
perspective at DePaul if Shapiro says
that black lives matter is a negative
movement that hurts black people and he
says the cops are deliberately murdering
black people on mass that hurts black
people black people feel bad and not
only they feel bad maybe it will prompt
some violence against black people in
some unspecified way therefore we have
to keep Shapiro off campus now typically
the right has responded to this nonsense
of mockery right we call them snowflakes
we say this is microaggression culture
it's a bunch of nonsense but now because
the left for so long has been blaming
acts of violence individual acts of
violence on the so called toxic climate
created by the right now the right
finally has its chance to do the same
things left and some people are
unwilling to forgo the revenge in favor
of the actual principle which is
actually dangerous if you are more
interested in revenge on the left than
you are in upholding a principle to
prevent the left from winning then you
are doing something counterproductive so
in the aftermath of this Bernie Sanders
supporting Trump hating terrorists
trying to shoot a bunch of Congress
people and succeeding Steve Scalise is
still in apparently critical condition
in the hospital there are a lot of
people on the right who have been making
the mistake of essentially claiming that
rhetoric causes violence anomaly is
rhetoric cause violence is leftist
rhetoric and not just leftist violent
rhetoric which okay but leftist normal
rhetoric like stuff that exists in the
realm of the normal this is dangerous so
I think that you know the natural
tendency after a horrible terrorist
incident like this occurs is for
everybody to come together the problem
is when the coming together is about
civility and niceness and then anytime
somebody says something that is
inflammatory or passionate about
politics is out shut that guy down he
might cause a nutcase to go and shoot
somebody you're starting to see this
happen so Scott Pelley over at CBS News
he says violence almost always begins
with words this is going to be the new
routine later at a lunch for reporters
President Trump was asked whether he
worried that that language would incite
violence
his paws indicated it had never crossed
his mind and then he said no that
doesn't worry me as children were taught
words will never hurt me but when you
think about it violence almost always
begins with words in Twitter world we've
come to believe that our first thought
is our best thought it's past time for
all of us
presidents politicians reporters
citizens all of us to pause to think
again okay so you can see why the left
is doing this okay so the left is saying
this the left is doing this because they
specifically are interested in pressing
forward the the right is uncivil the
right is terrible how dare the right use
the kind of language that's been using
Paul Ryan and Nancy Pelosi did a joint
interview yesterday at the Congressional
baseball game in which they did a little
bit of the same routine how do you
balance letting Republicans in your
caucus speak their mind while also
setting setting a roll I love being a
role model and saying that's too far
you've gone too far don't say that which
happens sometimes in soldiers offices
sure but I think all of us have a
responsibility to watch our rhetoric but
we were passionate we believed
passionately about our causes about our
issues and we can do that without being
vitriolic without omentum the kind of
anger that's out there in the country so
that's what leaders do and that's what
members of Congress have in common upon
them okay that's all fine this is all
fine this is all unified but here's
what's happened the left has now turned
to okay Trump's rhetoric is really
dangerous it's going to get people
killed
right Trump the right their rhetoric can
get people killed your Senator Richard
Blumenthal
who is a radical leftist from
Connecticut making exactly this case
need to seize this moment and tone down
the rhetoric I know that's easier said
than done and part of the problem is
that the president is continuing the
very visceral and vehement attacks
instead of saying as my colleague
senator Rubio said that he welcomes a
swift result and a fair result to this
investigation and again
it's amazing a leftist shoots up a
Republican congressional baseball
practice and the response is clearly
that the Republican rhetoric is the
problem the Republican rhetoric and I
can see why people on the right get
angry that's right
Jeff Flake did some of the same stuff
yesterday this is the senator from
Arizona he says that you know Trump
should stop calling people losers that's
the real problem here when you say you
want the president to lead is there
something specific you think he could do
that would maybe be a positive jolt to
the system well the things that he could
stop doing you know referring to others
in the other party as losers or or using
other language that just isn't becoming
and is it's done on our side as well and
certainly the president's opponent use
that kind of language the language
police are here so here's how the right
to respond to the language police with
blur I should say is what I said
yesterday violent rhetoric is not okay
defending violence is not okay but
passionate rhetoric you know the normal
passionate rhetoric of every day that
stuff is not only okay it's necessary in
a republic okay it's always existed in a
republic that doesn't mean that it's all
factual it doesn't mean it's all good
but it is necessary and to pretend that
it's going to stop is just it's just a
cudgel to wield against the other side
so laura ingraham i think that's exactly
wrong there's going to be a rare
situation in which I think that Laura
Ingraham is wrong and Nancy Pelosi is
kind of right which is just unbelievably
shocking and it just demonstrates how
people on either side of the aisle
partisanship Trump's principle here's
Laura Ingraham talking about leftist
rhetoric and what she thinks causes
violence but it's a level of viciousness
and vitriol that we see on social media
but usually that's an anonymous thing
but help you blur emboldened and they're
actually saying it in person they're
doing shock drawings of people and their
families on their driveways so they wake
up in the morning and they say a chalk
drawing but I think Charles is right
this apocalyptic language we hear on
other cable networks where they are
these are supposedly very respected
hosts who get up every morning and say
will our republic survive Donald Trump
in other words the resistance is a
physical resistance if you believe your
survival is at risk it's almost you have
a moral duty to physically resist that
okay again this is so hypocritical and
I'll explain why in a second Nancy
Pelosi says the right needs to stop
being sanctimonious about this stuff yes
because I think the what should stop
being sanctimonious about a years ago
people should stop being sanctimonious
about the idea that Sarah Palin putting
out on her website of congressional
districts that she wants to target
somehow leads to people dying
what should stop saying that talk radio
leads to the Oklahoma City bombing and
the right should not imitate the left in
an act of revenge here's Nancy Pelosi
saying that the right is being
sanctimonious yes and the left should
also stop being sanctimonious and I
think that the comments made by my
Republican colleagues are outrageous
beneath the dignity of the job that they
hold the needs of dignity of the respect
that we would like Congress to command
how dare they say such a thing how dare
they I well I don't even go into the
whole thing I can't even be getting
caricatures of me and George at once
again we're in over a hundred million
dollars of vitriolic things that they
say that resulted in calls to my homes
constantly threats in front of my
grandchildren even really predicated on
their comments and their paid ads so
this sick individual does something
despicable and it was horrible what he
did hateful but for them to all of a
sudden be sanctimonious and see if they
don't never seen such a thing before and
I don't even go into the President of
the United States
okay and the reason that I think that
she's not wrong here is because he heard
Laura Ingraham there say this
apocalyptic language we hear on other
cable networks okay I was alive six
months ago I remember when people are on
Fox News were saying on a routine basis
that the world was going to end if
Hillary Clinton was elected in fact this
was the best argument in favor of
President Trump okay here is the fact
the most read essay of the last election
cycle in right wing intellectual circles
was the flight 93 essay in the Claremont
Review of Books we talked about it at
the time it was quoted breathlessly by
everybody from Rush Limbaugh to Laura
Ingraham to Sean Hannity to my friend
Dennis Prager I mean it was quoted
everywhere and the basic idea there was
that if Hillary Clinton was elected that
the plane of state would crash and
everyone would die it literally said in
that essay charged the cockpit or you
die okay Ann Coulter said that Hillary's
election would be the quote end of them
erricka then it said that America could
quote never recover from her or any
Democrats victory Ingram herself who's
talking about apocalyptic language she
wrote a piece two weeks ago but two
weeks before the election tidal quote
how the elites blew up the world now is
my point that nobody should ever use
language like this know precisely the
opposite my point is that this has
always been the language of politics it
may not be right I may disagree with
this language I may have thought that
all those people were wrong about the
last election cycle and I may have
thought their apocalyptic language was
wrong in fact I did I said that the
plate 93 essay was stupid and incoherent
but the fact is nobody who read that
essay actually thought that this is a
flight 93 election nobody thought
Hillary was elected it was time to go
pick up a gun and start shooting
Democrats nobody thought that when
Dennis said that America would never
recover from Hillary's presidency that
that meant that it was time to go and
violently uprise against the Democratic
Party when Ingram said the elites blow
up the world nobody actually thought
that Trump should go out there and
commit bombings in response right we
always use this kind of rhetoric this
rhetoric is not new okay we've been
using rhetoric with the war on drugs the
war on poverty FDR targeted the quote
malefactors of great wealth this stuff
goes back all the way in the American
Republic the language of people being
enemies but we all understand there's a
baseline level understanding we're not
actually enemies there's a difference
between the Democrats with whom we argue
and Isis that actually wants to chop off
our head and I think that Republicans
are making a huge mistake if they feed
the snowflakes don't feed the snowflakes
don't feed the snowflakes do not buy
into the idea that is now being
promulgated by the right because we want
to stick the left space in it that
rhetoric leads to violence normal
political rhetoric that is edgy and
passionate leads to violence it is very
difficult to claim that college campuses
should allow people like me or Heather
McDonald or Charles Murray or ayaan
Hirsi Ali let alone my lowly innopolis
speak at the same time they say the word
resistance could cause violence when
we're Ingram says you know the
resistance that means physical
resistance that's the dumbest crap I've
ever heard okay it's really stupid no
one in the resistance or at least very
few people in the quote-unquote
resistance think it's time to pick up a
gun and start shooting people if they do
they are outliers there are truly
violent people like an Tifa I don't want
to lump in everybody who's on the other
side of the aisle with an Tifa because
that's not fair and it's not
right as begging it is begging for the
next time somebody who has a mention of
Sean Hannity in their manifesto or Laura
Ingraham in their manifesto it is
begging the left to do the exact same
routine on us that makes the political
situation up we are not better
it never gets more civil it just uses
civility as a club to beat the other
side and then we say okay well you're
beating us up so we're going to be even
less civil to you it just leads to a
downward spiral in both civility and the
level of political discourse that is
really really really stupid okay
before I go any further I want to talk
about President Trump I had a tweet
storm this morning about obstruction
we're going to talk about whether
obstruction is really on the table and
the latest leaks we're going to talk
about all that plus my father is going
to stop by my pops is going to stop by
and we're going to talk about our
brand-new book say it's so papa dad made
and the 2005 White Sox championship
season we were doing mailbag Justin
might yeah we have lots of questions
from listeners who want to ask my dad
questions but before we get to any of
that I first want to say thank you to
our friends over at the United States
concealed-carry Association so this is a
fantastic organization they provide
industry-leading firearms education
training and self-defense insurance if
you are living in a state like
California or even not a state like
California and you have to shoot
somebody in self-defense
good shot you're going to get caught up
in some sort of legal turmoil UFC CA
makes sure that you know what you need
to know and they help provide resources
for your self-defense they provide
self-defense insurance so that you are
covered legally they're also about
getting more guns into the hands of
responsible freedom-loving Americans
there's a story today about gun owners
who are able to protect themselves from
convicted murderers who would escape
prison because there were gun owners
everybody who's a law-abiding citizen
should have a gun and should know how to
use it
that's what USC CA is there for and
right now they have this really awesome
deal they are going to buy ten of my
listeners the gun of their dreams that's
right you're about to get ten chances to
win $1,500 for any gun that you want ten
chances to win $1,500 for any gun that
you want go to defend my family now.com
to enter defend my family now calm it's
a fantastic website it's it's right now
they actually have a separate deal that
says you can be one of five people
who'll win one that even more money one
thousand seven hundred and seventy six
dollars right now when you go and you
register over at defend my freedom
defend my family now calm
then my family now calm you can win 1776
dollars for the gun of your choice gun
enamel of your choice super awesome one
of five people will win so five of my
listeners can win 1776 dollars in honor
of July 4th it's a great American
giveaway July 4th if the deal is going
to end soon so you want to go and
register right now defend my family now
combos and you should be registered
there anyway room you should be
registered there in any case again
that's super cool you get five chances
to win at 1776 dollar 70 1776 be
patriotic and a gun right you SCCA
defend my family now calm it's super
super cool program ok so I want to
discuss briefly what President Trump has
been doing because there's a bunch of
breaking news the left of course is
going nuts over new leaks but before we
get to any of that you're going to have
to go over and become a subscriber over
at daily wire comm for eight dollars a
month you too can get a subscription to
daily wire comm and you can be one of
the cherished few that's participate in
today's mail that I believe we're doing
live mailbag today also if you have live
questions and you register right now you
can be part of the mailbag my dad is
stopping by for the mailbag which is
super cool you get the rest of the show
live you get the mailbag you also get
Andrew Clavin show live and we have lots
of more goodies coming up we are
planning a big rollout of some new
programs for our subscribers plus annual
subscribers do right now get a free
signed copy of say it so Papa dad me and
the 2005 White Sox championship season
we will sign it for you I will sign it
for you and it is great Father's Day
gift hundreds and hundreds of people
have already done this and they're
enjoying the book immensely too about
fathers and sons in baseball so it
should be really cool all right if you
don't want to register right now if you
don't want to subscribe right now then
you can always go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and give us a listen we
always appreciate the listenership and
you can subscribe over there as well
make sure you leave a review we
appreciate that too this is largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]
you